Megan you said that uh you're 34 and
extremely single I think was a word that
used I
okay pretty single so not like totally
sing
guys who are non-committal and that's
been an issue Okay so
can you kind of take us down that a
little bit so what's your biggest dating
or relationship struggle right now being
uh
I like the guys that every other girl
likes
and I won't lower my standards so I mean
what does that guy look like can you
describe him uh
um usually around at least six foot and
definitely gym guy not like juicehead on
stage type guys
um but definitely like muscle guys
because I like to I do a lot of Gym
classes
um I'm not into like bodybuilding or
anything like that
um but yeah I like
I will bypass the guys who are the betas
for the Alphas
is
and they're not reciprocating or
um they are but sometimes they kind of
do the pullback when I want more
how does that go can you explain that
kind of like a lot
of these Alpha
but they know somebody else
is actively trying to get you
I have a lot of orbiters I guess we'll
say
orbiters in the sense where they're sort
of like low value guys or you're not
interested yeah yeah I'm not interested
at all
so
there's a lot in the
front okay so what's your goal like
you're looking for boyfriend marriage
like what are you trying to do here
um I mean I don't really have an end
goal but I guess marriage but I'm kind
of used to living alone at this point
but it's not ideal okay so what would
the ideal guy look like to you
um good job
uh Republican
[Music]
um
not like I like the man's man not beta
type
oh characteristics
okay so you said Republican good job
man's man so we just had
um I guess we can use George as an
example on the Tua call-in because he's
uh he looks like a republican dude man's
man he's tall uh he installs HVAC he
makes about 55 000 a year how does that
work out for you
thought I think
I think previous
Jim sorry
I mean if you don't want an intro
maybe but okay so more accurately
describe this this this high value man
that that you'd like to marry you know
if you give us more than just Republican
you know good job like how much money
does he have to earns to be around
um
matter
that much to me because I
child and I'm pretty I'm pretty well set
you're set yeah but I mean like you know
that women don't typically like to date
down funny honey pot or whatever yeah so
women don't typically like to date down
I mean they want to be with a guy that
can make it rain so how much money does
he have to make to be with Megan
um say at least I don't know like 75. 75
grand
so I mean there's got to be loads of
Republican guys that make 75 grand that
are man's man and
your area not in Pittsburgh no no not
many why not
or if there are there are like 55.
so they're they're older
yeah I don't really like that okay so
what I've tried going on like dinner
dates with older guys I can't get into
it though I actually like to go a little
younger
okay so what's younger for you
to go out tomorrow
at a bar Friday and Saturday
and Saturday okay so when you're looking
for a younger guy that likes to party
then
yeah but also like Work Hard Play Hard
type of thing I don't mind that it's
when it's all just play hard that's kind
of an issue it's a turn off so what's
play hard is that like three nights a
week we're going out drinking partying
is that four nights is that five nine oh
no no like for the guys it's every
single Friday and Saturday which I'm not
that excited about going to like okay so
maybe I misheard you because I because I
thought you said that you like to go out
a couple nights a week to drink oh no no
me no the guys do the guys do so what
you're looking for is
not an outside guy like an extrovert
drink party like what are you looking
for I'm I do like
traverts
um I mean I like to do certain events
but I'm not just because it's a Friday
night gonna go to a bar just because
it's Friday type thing you know I would
rather take a trip and do other things
all right so I want to try to be helpful
to Megan here because we've got uh
Leandra and Aaron you know on the line
they're both in long-term relationships
you know they found guys
um right I think the easiest thing to do
is rather than dispense any advice right
now ask some clarifying questions of
Megan so that you understand her
predicament a little bit better so
Leandra do you want to go ahead and ask
any clarifying questions yeah I'm open
to
I don't get offended
I'm really curious what is the
attraction to younger men you're
probably the first woman I've heard in
our 30s that is attractive to younger
men yeah I know
[Music]
um
they don't have as much baggage as
the guys around my age sprocket does
that mean like they haven't had kids and
they haven't been married yeah right
correct yeah okay
are you opposed to like do you want to
have kids
do you but I'm not that's not like my
mission right now like if it happens but
yeah statistically like I think what is
it if you don't have kids by the time
you're 35 yeah 50 of women won't yeah
yeah I work in the
it classified as like geriatric
pregnancy right it's crazy yeah if you
have you ever like
listed out what you want your man to
look like like in detail like what does
he do how
I think no it just sounds like you're a
little all over the place where it's you
want younger guys but you don't want
guys that party I feel like that almost
goes hand in hand most of the time yeah
it does
but you look like you have questions
like
you had said Megan that you kind of
aren't looking for something very
committal that you're looking for maybe
more just fun like temporary
relationships well yeah no the guys that
I tend to go for aren't looking for
anything coming at all oh yeah sorry my
service oh I've just finished
misunderstood
well do you think that
um
like with with dating a younger guy in
him having you know your
your like salary requirement or not
requirement but preference yeah
um
I I'm just wondering how that's gone for
you like have you been able to find what
you're looking for
no no
um because I almost it seems like with
the guys who are just a little bit
younger I almost have to pretend that
I'm renting even though I'm not renting
you know what I mean because they're
renting and I I feel like they almost
and I don't want to use the word
intimidated but they I don't know I
think they're used to the 22 year old
girls who are living with three other
girls and have like pizza boxes
everywhere type thing you know I don't
know yeah
it seems confusing to me because I mean
you're describing young fun virile but
yeah so on the other hand want
responsible together sorted
handsome masculine man's man I know I'm
all over the place like I know so do you
see the like the issue yeah right yeah
when was your last relationship I'm
curious
I would like a year and a half ago and
how long was that
that was around that was going on three
years but he actually moved and I
to move with him can you describe him
for us how old was he what did he do for
a living
he was three years older than me
and a very good job
um he was a
Financial guy
um
Hobbies he traveled a lot for work which
was a little bit
not sketchy but
what do you do for a living
uh he was in finance okay so he traveled
for work for working with different
banks financial institutions meetings
yeah why was that sketchy
not sketchy but I know that he would
definitely like go out while he was
there
okay because a friend of mine told me
that she saw him in the city that he was
in on like a dating app but he had a
fake name on there so
dating app under a fake name and a
different scene and your friend saw him
what did he say when you confronted him
oh of course he denied it
um
did you guys have a problem with that
was he going outside of the relationship
oh I'm sure
as you say like I don't know how
monogamous
can be they're kind of just trying to
look the other way
no I mean I definitely made an issue of
it for a while
but you didn't break up with him over it
like you guys woke up because you moved
okay let's say he had said like yeah I
was on the app you caught me what of it
I mean is that you know if he had if he
had come clean about it is that
something that would have actually made
him look better in your eyes or worse
I would say
probably I guess better
yeah but I feel like I know I shouldn't
say I feel like that's like that bad
terminal your men are totally allowed to
open any statement okay
um
I only harp on the guys on that one
I feel like a lot of guys do that on
dating apps though that's why I'm not
hugely for them
so where else are you looking
for guys if you don't like the dating
apps
uh I tried to
[Music]
here what kind of events
well on Saturday I was at this
um it was at like it was a benefit it
was a polo event
with a doctor like one of the doctors I
work with had a bunch of tickets
are you in Pharmacy it's very waspy no
I'm
nails but I want to
see okay
um no uh there was a there's a comment
in here I wonder if Megan agrees with
this or not somebody said in the
comments that you seem it's you seem
like it's very you get bored easily in
that you I do high entertainment
threshold and so do guys often feel like
they don't bring enough to the table for
you to keep you entertained
yeah I do think that
but I mean let's be honest like a guy in
his late 20s isn't going to be as
entertaining
as a guy that's more competent and
sorted closer
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full-length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out